PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video I'd
like us to practice
some of the
approximation techniques
we've learned in the lectures.
So in this one
specifically, what
I'd like us to do is estimate
the integral from 0 to pi
of sin x dx using these
two approximation methods.
a is going to be using
the trapezoid rule,
and b is going to be
using Simpson's rule.
In both cases, I'd like you
to do this for n equal 4,
and to get you started I have
drawn a little sketch of what
y equals sin x looks like on
the interval from 0 to pi.
So I'll give you a while
to work on this and then
when you're finished
you can come back
and I'll show you how I do it.
OK.
Welcome back.
Hopefully you were able
to get an approximation
for both of these.
Now I'll show you how
I do it and make sure
that you're doing it
in the correct way.
So I've done a little bit
of work ahead of time,
because I didn't want to
have to write everything down
in the video.
So if you come over here
to the right a little bit,
we'll see that
I've actually made
myself a table of the important
x-values and y-values.
And if you recall,
what I said is
we're going to approximate
the integral from 0
to pi using four sub-intervals.
So we're interested in
i going from 0 to 4,
and then we need to subdivide
that interval from 0
to pi into four
equal sub-intervals.
So that will be
length pi over 4.
So x_0 is just 0,
x_1 is pi over 4.
x_2 is pi over 2,
you get the idea.
x sub 4 is pi.
And then what I've done, is to
make it really easy on myself,
is I've determined what
the y-values are associated
to that x-value, given
that my function is sin x.
So I filled in a table of
values for myself right away,
and then when I want
to use the two rules,
I can simply come back
and look at this table.
So the first thing I'm going
to do is the trapezoid rule.
So I'll come back over
here a little bit.
So using the trapezoid
rule, let's remember
what the trapezoid rule is.
The trapezoid rule is delta
x times, in this case,
we're going to have y_0 over
2 plus y_1 plus y_2 plus y_3
plus y_4 over 2.
So let me actually move that.
So remember, what you get
is you get essentially
you're averaging the right and
the left hand end point ones.
So you end up with the furthest
left has a 1/2 coefficient,
the furthest rights has a 1/2,
all the other coefficients
are equal to 1.
So what do we get when we
actually evaluate this?
When we plug in what we have
for delta x and for all these
values.
Delta x, we know
again, it should
be the length of the
interval divided by n.
We're sub-dividing equally here.
So we get pi over 4.
And then let's
look at our values.
Well, y_0 and y_4
are both 0, so I'm
going to not even put those in.
You'll see 0 there, 0 there,
so these two are both 0.
So I just have to
substitute in these values.
y_1, y_2, and y_3.
So y sub 1 is root 2
over 2, y sub 2 is 1,
and y sub 3 is root 2 over 2.
So I should get root 2 over
2 plus 1 plus root 2 over 2.
And if you want to simplify a
little bit, you can do that.
Root 2 over 2 plus root
2 over 2, is root 2.
Hopefully you got something
that looked like this.
And I gotta tell you at
this point, I'm stopping.
Because I don't want to bother
to simplify any more than this.
But the main point is, I want
to make sure we understand,
once we have this method how
to substitute everything in.
So this first one was just
using the trapezoid rule
to approximate the integral.
Now, what does that actually
mean in terms of the graph?
Let's go back to the
graph and let's look
at what that actually means.
I'm going to get
another color for this.
So in the case of the trapezoid
rule, what that means,
I'm sub-dividing the
interval like this
and the trapezoid
rule, remember,
connects the two y-values.
Consecutive y-values here.
And it's giving you the
area of each of those.
So we found the blue, we
found the blue shaded area
with the trapezoid rule.
So just to recall, that's
actually what we did.
This is a fairly
good approximation,
looks like in this case, of
what the actual integral is.
So now let's do Simpson's rule.
And I'll come over to
the right of the table
to do Simpson's rule.
Now notice I can
do Simpson's rule
because n is an even number.
I have to have n even in
order to do Simpson's rule.
So just to remind us
what Simpson's rule is,
Simpson's rule is
delta x over 3 and then
I have these funny coefficients,
which at some point
we will explain.
I have a 1 in front of
y_0, a 4 in front of y_1,
2 in front of y_2, a 4
in front of y_3, and a 1
in front of the y sub 4.
So that's exactly
the coefficients
for Simpson's rule.
And you saw in class
why this is a 2.
You'll see in another
recitation video
why we end up
getting the 1, 4, 1.
And those two things add
up, 1, 4, 1; 1, 4, 1.
And where the 3 comes from.
We'll show all of
that in another video.
So let's fill in what we have.
Well delta x is pi over 4 so
I get pi over 4 times 1/3,
so I get pi over 12.
y_0 is again 0.
y_1, come back here,
it was root 2 over 2.
Root 2 over 2 times
4 is 2 root 2.
y_2, if you remember, was 1.
So I get 2 times 1 is 2.
And then I have the
same two values.
Because this is a-- this is
symmetric about the y_2 value.
So I get another 2
root 2, and another 0.
So if I simplify all this, I get
pi over 12-- oops-- pi over 12
and then I get 4 root 2 plus 2.
And so that we can maybe see
a little bit more what it,
how it compares, we can
simplify this a little bit.
I'm going to put the 1 in
front, 1 plus 2 root 2.
Now, if you wanted to actually
do a comparison of those two
values, and then compare
that to the actual integral,
you'd want to evaluate
the actual integral
and then maybe look at what
these two are on a calculator.
But, I just wanted
to make sure we
knew how to plug in the y-values
and the appropriate delta
x to the appropriate formula.
So, again, what we
were trying to do
is estimate the integral for
one that we actually know,
so we could do some
comparison if we wanted.
And see how these
numerical methods,
or these approximations
actually work.
So we did trapezoid rule,
we had the formula up there.
We did Simpson's rule and
the formula's right here.
And when we were doing this,
the thing that made it simpler
is at the very beginning I
made a nice table of values.
So when you're solving
these types of problems
that might be something
you want to think
about doing right at
the very beginning
to make things a little
simpler for yourself.
And I think I'll stop there.